i
ah
[Música]
el estable y por primera vez estaba
viendo un hombre morir al frente mío
estábamos en el desierto del sahara y
pablo al igual que todos recibió en la
botella de agua
pablo resolvió ser conservador y abrirla
y tomarla de sorbo en suelo muy
lentamente
la organización lo encontró botado en
medio de la nada
estaba al borde de la muerte y tuvieron
que ponerle 5 sueros para que viva era
la primera noche se estaba muriendo en
el sahara pero con una botella de agua
llena
y esa cosa que parezca absurda fue lo
que me lleva a la reflexión de la
botella de agua que tenemos todos aquí
es una botella llena de sueños de
motivaciones de habilidades de
conocimientos destrezas conexiones pero
que muy pocos estamos atreviéndonos a
tomarla y si la tomamos la estamos
tomando muy lentamente el problema es
que no sabemos cuándo nos vamos a morir
y tampoco sabemos a qué velocidad
debemos tomar esa botella de agua
soy de guayaquil y me crié en un barrio
marginal bastante pobre con limitaciones
en todo alcohol drogas pandillas
el acceso a servicios básicos y demás mi
mamá a los 11 años nos reunió con mis
hermanos y nos dijo hemos trabajado
junto a tu padre toda la vida pero no
vamos a alcanzar dejarles un patrimonio
interesante vamos a apostarle a la
educación
esa tarde fui a jugar pelota allí en mi
barrio y vi este mural y decía si el
reto no te hace a temblar las piernas
quizás no es lo suficientemente grande
para ti yo a mis 11 años ni siquiera
entendía esto lo entendería años después
cuando me cambié a quito y yo ya corría
más o menos en quintos dos kilómetros
quizás para impresionar a alguna pelada
algo así pero me cambio a quito y llegó
a correr cinco kilómetros en un mes me
emociono y voy a inscribirme en una
carrera y el señor de la tienda me dice
mira 10 20 50 y 80 kilómetros 10 y 20
están llenos si quieres 50 y 80
kilómetros y yo le dijo dame 50 pues
entonces y el más media 50 y me meten un
relajo imposible enojan de imbabura 50
kilómetros que no tenía idea cómo
hacerlo cuando llegó a la carrera
todo el mundo estaba equipado era como
una especie de de linternas voz mochila
y bastones y demás yo llevaba un mes en
en la capital y fue con camisetas sin
mangas pantalones está chiquita zapatos
y con una chompa amarrada como
en el colegio así metido para hacer 50
km ahí me di cuenta que no sabiendo
estaba parado y digo bueno al final del
día yo voy a correr 10 kilómetros así
que en el 10 me retiro efectivamente en
el 9 me retiré yuma me dice no no no no
puedes votar t cuando te dé la gana
estás en montaña en montaña se vota en
ciertos puntos
y el siguiente donde queda en el
kilómetro 15 y allí entiendo la primera
elemento el primer elemento en esta
fórmula y se llama enfoque tenemos que
tener un propósito yo estaba en el
kilómetro 9 en medio de la nada en un
problema del tamaño de 50 kilómetros no
me queda nada más que enfocada me han
llegado a los 50 kilómetros si no
tenemos un propósito en la vida estamos
perdiendo el tiempo si hoy se ha
despertado bien no tienen claro por qué
vinieron están perdiendo el tiempo si no
pueden responder porque se ha despertado
en la semana pasada seguramente están
perdiendo el tiempo regreso el problema
es que no sabemos cuándo nos vamos a
morir y tienen esa botella pero no
sabemos cuándo utilizar las 15 horas
después acabó esta carrera
bar atado destrozado soy el último en
llegar contento pero con una gran duda
si las personas crecemos cuando
enfrentamos a nuestros miedos me quedo
con esa duda y seis meses después
patagonia argentina 160 kilómetros mi
cálculo alegre fue a ver si ya corre 50
estaban en las como hace unas tres
vueltas más diez de yapa resuelto el
resuelvo esa multiplicación embargo en
esto compra del pasaje me inscribo seis
meses estaba en la patagonia 160
kilómetros que acabó en 58 horas no me
quedó claro como él acabe
pero la clave
dejándome dos días después solamente
repetía lo que la gente hacía si paraban
en un riachuelo a [ __ ] agua yo hacía lo
mismo si los manes sacaban unos polvos y
les ponían ahí hacían un batido yo que
no cargaba eso les preguntaba hoy y que
eso no es proteína para dice qué cosa
haber de saber de agave y probaba y así
iba rebotando 58 horas una desgracia
completa regreso cuando agarró confianza
y digo bueno pues veamos a ver qué hay y
así como uno busca cosas importantes
cuando quedó barceló onda
el vestido de las kardashian o cualquier
cosa yo puse la carrera más difícil en
el mundo no para hacerla sino por sapo y
esto me lleva al desierto del sahara 240
kilómetros en el lugar más caliente de
la tierra discovery channel le había
dado el premio a la carrera más difícil
del mundo y yo que no era un correo ni
profesional ni a tiempo completo quería
hacerla y me embarcó en esta aventura
pero sabía que para esta aventura había
que además de un equipo el segundo
elemento en la fórmula
tienes que armar un equipo no hay forma
de hacer cosas grandes solo es
interesantísimo esta parte porque me
toca hacer una reunión entre
fisioterapia físico alimentación
fisiología y psicología todo un equipo
técnico ninguno de mis cinco amigos
había experimentado un desafío tan
grande como ir al sahara pero teníamos
un elemento en común el reto profesional
cuando tú logras que las motivaciones
individuales se hundan en una colectiva
estás realmente creando un trabajo en
equipo y así llegó el primer día este es
creo que es el mejor resumen de la vida
vamos
a este motivo solo
una hora es buena
sobre luna
los he vuelto a apoyarme
- metatarsos sobre las ampollas
para dejarlos descansar a los talones
y así
así pasaré creo que el resto del día así
pasé el resto del día porque el
entrenamiento estaba claro déjame seguir
avanzando en esto nada más el
entrenamiento estaba claro aunque yo
había entrenado nueve meses siete meses
en guayaquil corriendo zapatos y
corriendo con zapatos sin medias para
que se hagan ampollas porque la clave
era que se me revienten los pies para
tener una capa grande para que pueda
aguantar el calor de la arena a mí el
vallenato no me gusta y yo escuchen de
esa vaina horas en guayaquil al mediodía
porque me estaba entrenando mentalmente
para todas que se me venía y según yo y
según yo las ampollas miran a salida en
el día tres panas me salían en el día 2
ahí están mis pies reventados 6 ampollas
tuvieron que cortarme con un bisturí
hacerme un hueco hacer el borde me
empapelaron los pies
yo no podía caminar llevaba 80 km y me
sentía llorar porque el sueño se me
había acabado me faltaban 160 kilómetros
y no tenía idea cómo hacerlo pero al
siguiente día entendí
y hay una fuerza mucho más fuerte que la
propia y que el propio cerebro o que la
propia mente se llama espíritu esa llama
interna que es la que marca seguir tu
sueño tu única responsabilidad en el
mundo al final del día debería ser hacer
cosas que tú quieres hacer y que por lo
tanto son tus propios sueños y
obviamente tu propia responsabilidad
seis días después acabó y estos son los
20 minutos 20 metros más importancia de
todas las minutos
con sus palabras
[Música]
pero veamos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
hace 1 año un año atrás era una locura
todo el mundo me dijo que era imposible
pero te das cuenta que si sigues tus
sueños y los trabajas brutalmente en
algún rato lo vas a conseguir y te
sientes rambo pues no y te sientes rambo
y dices ya pues si ya acabaste en el
lugar más caliente de la tierra
metámonos al más frío y nace esta
aventura la antártida 100 kilómetros en
el lugar más frío del planeta aquí está
el 90% del hielo del mundo aquí se ha
registrado la temperatura más baja de la
historia de la humanidad
- 89 grados centígrados y este mono que
no había pisado nieve que no había
vivido un invierno de verdad un invierno
macho que su concepto de frío era el
aire acondicionado y quería meterse a
correr 100 kilómetros y habíamos sufrido
tanto en el sahara que el elemento de
riesgo en la fórmula de indispensable
había que poner ese elemento en esta
fórmula para hacer cosas imposibles e
identificamos dos riesgos el primer
riesgo no podía parar porque
sencillamente me congelaría y el segundo
primero es que no podía detenerme a
orinar adecuamos bolsillos en la malla y
probamos toallas yo me probé las 14
toallas sanitarias del país las 14
estaba buscando la más delgada la más
absorbente la de mejor agarre y todo
porque si se me regalaba el orines se me
iba a mojar de esto y se nacía en llagas
iba a bajar esa velocidad y me
congelaría comprenderán que estaba en el
polo sur y no había vuelta atrás no
había una operación suficiente y así
llegó al ara a la antártida
ahí estaba minutos previos yo sabía que
abría esa puerta y no había vuelta atrás
100 kilómetros me esperaban y empieza la
carrera y le doy lamentablemente paro
dos veces la primera en el kilómetro 6
creo por un tema de zapatos lo puede
resolver rapidito unos 4 minutos y la
segunda se me complicó el tendón en la
rodilla tuve que bajar la velocidad me
empecé a congelar había llevado unas
jeringas para auto inyectarme por si
acaso pase eso y efectivamente pasó en
esa duda me inyecto no me inyecto me
inyecto no me inyecto
dos minutos estaba completamente
congelado me inyecté las piernas se me
calentó pero si me faltaban más jeringas
para el otro cuerpo ya me dolían los
hombros los codos las muñecas caderas
rodillas tobillos todo era un infierno
logré correr por fin y me prometí a mí
mismo no volver a parar hasta que llegue
a la meta final llegó a la meta final
después de 16 horas no por rápido llegó
en cuarto lugar sino porque quería salir
de ese infierno pero él acabó me
convierte en el primero ecuatoriano y me
metí en un grupo de 14 personas en el
mundo que han sido capaces de correr más
de 100 kilómetros en el lugar más
caliente de la tierra y más frío del
planeta y orgullosamente ahí hay un
ecuatoriano
y de ahí
muchas gracias
y de ahí empieza esta vocecita y dices
si ya corriste en el lugar de más
caliente de la tierra y ya corriste en
el lugar más frío de la tierra y ahora
oracle y luego y digo metámonos pues
entonces al más profundo del planeta y
conectamos lo con el más cercano al sol
y el más profundo está en sudáfrica
y ahí queríamos correr 21 kilómetros
salí a la superficie tomar un vuelo
llegar a ecuador y conectarlo con el
punto base del canal sol y al final del
día la pregunta era qué hacemos que fue
como la utilizada pues la misma fórmula
de siempre y de que habla de futuro que
habla de avance que habla de que si lo
voy a poder hacer no es una fórmula
perfecta pero si me ha venido
funcionando hasta ahora y bueno como una
es pobre pero antojado y eso es a esos
eventos les dijimos bueno hagamos una
película y hagamos una película
ecuatoriana de talla mundial y ahora
orgullosamente ya está en carteleras y
le estamos compartiendo porque es una
experiencia inolvidable sólo para
terminar amigos quiero dejarles una
pequeña pregunta nada más
todos tenemos límites aquí todos y
tenemos dos caminos el primero
adecuamos nuestra vida a esos límites
vivimos sin hacer mayor cosa y con
nuestra botella llena y muchas veces sin
destapar la así como pablo y la 2ª
entendemos que la vida es efímera que no
sabemos cuándo se ha acabado cuando se
va a acabar y que nuestra
responsabilidad efectivamente es vivirla
empujando cada vez esos límites quizás
con la fórmula de lo imposible al final
cada uno decide qué hacer con ellos
[Aplausos]